Hello and welcome everyone.
This is Actinflab Livestream number 36.2.
It's January 26, 2022.
Welcome to Active Inference Lab.
We are a participatory online lab that is communicating, learning, and practicing applied
active inference.
You can find us at the links here on this page.
This is a recorded and an archived livestream, so please provide us with feedback so we can
improve our work.
All backgrounds and perspectives are welcome, and we'll be following good video etiquette
for livestreams.
Check out ActiveInference.org if you want to learn more about what Actinflab is up to,
or if you want to participate in any of the activities which include livestreams in the
communications organizational unit, but a ton of other stuff is happening.
Today in 36.2, our third discussion on 36.
We're going to continue to learn and discuss this paper by Sims and Pazulo 2021, Modeling
Ourselves, What the Free Energy Principle Reveals About Our Implicit Notions of Representation,
and we're going to have a nice jumping off dot two as we do, and have some questions
written down and prepared.
Other things will spontaneously arise, and if anyone watching live wants to just write
a question in a live chat, we can also address that.
We'll start with an introduction, so we'll go around and introduce ourselves.
People can say anything they want, and they can also add just what got them excited about
the paper in general, or for this dot two discussion specifically.
So I'm Daniel, I'm a researcher in California, and just excited to see how this representation
in discussion influences our own self representation, and that at the individual and the lab scale.
Moving forward, I'll pass it to Blue.
Hi, I'm Blue, I'm an independent research consultant in New Mexico, and I am excited
by this paper because in our previous discussions, we're, as usual, left with more questions
than answers, and also I kind of am finding myself swayed by the different representational
structural, content driven, non-representational, these different arguments, and I just find
them very interesting, and I just want to know if at the end of this, if I'll be swayed
more or less in certain directions, or maybe just be more open to other interpretations
of FEP, and I will pass it to Danielle.
Hello, I'm Danielle, I'm a cognitive scientist at Google with a background in language evolution,
language development.
I'm really interested in thinking about how humans evolve the ability to model other
minds, so interested in how this discussion can contribute to that, and generally interested
in how really good frameworks like the FEP can help kind of encompass other frameworks
and revise them.
Awesome.
Dean?
Hi, I'm Dean, I'm up here in Calgary, in Canada, and a little bit of recency effect,
I started watching Ozark the last season, and so I'm trying to plug this paper in through
what would Marty Bird do, so that's kind of my little twist on modeling.
So back to you, Daniel.
Who is Marty Bird, and what would he do?
Right, exactly.
Great question, well, that's all we prepared for today, so we'll go into the discussion.
But we have some things written down, is there anything just off the bat that anybody wants
to just ask or jump into, or like a figure, or a quotation to begin with, or we can look
at some of the things that we had written down.
Okay, let's just start with what we've written down, and then of course at any point we can
branch off.
Okay, I think a big theme that we'll probably return to again and again, is this idea of
moving back and forth from non-representational forms to representational forms.
In the paper, they introduce four different facets of representation, and then how each
of those facets can be approached in a representational or non-representational way.
And although the image here shows some solid black lines, that was kind of the discussion
was, is there movement across these areas or blurriness?
So maybe Dean, what is there to say or start to explore with representations emerging, like
almost precipitating or crystallizing out of something non-representational, and then
the reverse process of something that is more representational, submerging back into something
that's less?
Well, one of the things the authors did talk quite a bit about in terms of the functional
aspect of this was the vicarious nature, and then they also talked quite a bit about whether
or not somebody who's sort of moving in that radical inactivism space still has to be able
to differentiate and get some, include some of the temporal aspects of what might pop
up and become something that we can stabilize in model or representation form.
But then it has to also be able to disappear, right?
It also has to not necessarily consume everything in terms of our attentional field.
So I'm not really sure exactly how that works itself through, but I would think that it's
difficult to say that even if we're in a flow state, that there isn't some moment when we
do reflect in that mirror.
So that's kind of where I'm at.
I don't have any answers per se, but I don't want to get stuck in the idea that it's just
an on-off switch.
I think that there's a bit of a moment of dimming and then re-lighting.
So that makes me think about certain paths that our thought takes over these eight cells.
Like when we're in the representational side, when we're dealing with the representation,
how do we take that tetrahedra and look at the four different sides?
And then how do we stay within a column looking at just the organizational aspects of a system
and then move north and south on that?
Do these kinds of knowledge or cognitive transitions happen all the time?
Do they have other names that might be more familiar than using some of this philosophical
language?
What is it?
Are there any times in our days where we're dealing with something representationally
and we shift to a non-representational version within one of these categories or across categories?
So I was just thinking of that actually.
What does an organizational representation look like?
That is like a map, like a structural representation, a content-related representation, and a functional
representation.
And what do these representations look like?
And how are they different?
I was just thinking about that.
Let's go to the definition of the organizational representation, just to kind of remember.
The fact that FEP requires internal states, states that encode the recognition model,
that are statistically separated from the external reality.
So the organizational area is about how variables inside of systems are separated from variables
outside of the system.
The pro-representation take is there's an evidentiary boundary, the Markov blanket,
and there's something on the inside that is doing something like a representation on
what's outside.
So that's the pro-representational take.
Then the non-representational take is where we get into the ecological and the inactivist
persuasion.
And that's where the authors say that some have approached this Markov blanket structural
formalism, even though we're talking about it in the organizational, not the structural
facet, in a manner that suggests a non-representational view.
And they argue that just partitioning two coupled systems, like agent and environment,
with a Markov blanket doesn't imply that the behavior of the agent is explained by anything
related to an internal model that's doing anything like capturing the structure of the
outside world.
So you just used organizational and structural in this big hobnob, but my question was really,
what does an organizational representation look like?
And so I'm hearing that you answered that there are clearly defined boundaries in organizational
representation or partitions between internal and external states.
So when I have a representation in my mind that's organizational, it is like your boundary
is different from like, is it only your own boundary or is it like the boundaries of each
individual agent are organizationally represented in your mind?
Or is it just the boundary between you and the outside world?
And how might that differ from structural and content related, like what do these different
representations look like?
That's what I'm trying to see, like, would they be maps and how would the maps be different?
The structural, which does come up several times in the organizational definition.
So we see structure coming up, the structure of the system in how it's organized, but what
is the structural specifically, okay, having representational vehicles that are structurally
similar to the state of affairs in the world that they stand for.
The pro representational structural side is kind of like the good regulator theorem of
cybernetics.
So the organizational side is highlighting that there is some sort of informational encapsulation,
we might even say, like our previous discussions, but some sort of organization of variables
such that there's an inside and an outside that are separated.
And the structural side is saying that it's like if there's three things that are connected
in the outside world, then not just that there are variables that are organizationally
separated in the internal states, but that the structure of those isolated variables
is going to do something like recapitulate or have a structural resemblance to the generative
process.
Generative process, that's like the niche, that's what's outside generative model, that's
what the agent has on board.
And so if it's to be useful for control purposes, then it may have to have some sort of structural
resemblance to the actual connectivity of the generative process.
So generative model and generative process being separated is what's captured in the
organizational side, them having similar resemblances or similar structures is what the structural
side is.
The structural non representationalists are suggesting, this is I think tale of two densities
with Ramsted et al., or modeling ourselves.
The author suggests that generative models do not meet the requirements of structural
representations because the process of exploitable structural representations, so posterior beliefs
in the entity is enacted.
And so it doesn't necessarily have to recapitulate the form of the generative process, so maybe
one could be skilled in the performance of driving without having variables connected
in the way that a car pieces are connected.
It comes back to a theme that Active presents to us, perhaps more as a question than an answer,
which is how much do we have to know in order to act?
Do we have to have an internal model that is very similar to the process, uncorrelated
in how similar it is, anti correlated in how similar it is, and can we have a framework
as researchers that helps us compare the structure and organization of generative processes and
generative models of those processes?
Yes, go 14.
So I'll put this out there and then people push back or say it doesn't make any sense.
From what I read in the paper now, because I had to go back over and look at it again,
if I were to try to draw a simple comparison between organization and structure, organization
would you could see it as being something as being either in or out.
So you could be inside, you could be inside a cell or outside of a cell, then in our minds
we can tell we will draw those partitions and then we'll decide what's in or out.
Structural I think takes on more of the entailing question, something that Sir Wal brought up
in the chat, which is so once you've decided whether something's in or not, is there something
else that now can be seen as being superordinate to that from the perspective of sort of what's
wrapped around now the thing that's in or what can sit upon theoretically the thing
that you've now decided is foundational to whatever it is you're looking at and what
can be set aside as not being important to what you're looking at.
So again, pull that apart and say that that's wrong, but that's kind of what I try to read
into what the readers or what the writers were saying.
So it's just my interpretation.
Thanks Blue.
So I just wonder in this organizational representation, if you draw a distinction between, I mean
clearly there's one between like what's internal and external to yourself, but are you also
trying to like draw distinctions between what's internal and external to your computer or
your refrigerator or your best friend or your child, like are you making a representation
of everything that's internal and external to every other thing or is it only with respect
to your own self versus environment?
I would think it's when you do that.
I don't know that it's implied that you do it all the time.
But if you choose to do that, I think that that's something that's pretty easy to tell
the difference around.
So again, I'm not sure that they were saying that we do this, we're do always constantly
doing this, but I think what they were trying to do is show the difference between knowing
when something's in or out versus knowing when something's first or second from a structural
standpoint.
Again, I don't want to put words in the author's mouth, but I did hear that in the words that
they were doing to try to parse those two things and give each their due, as opposed
to saying they're just the same thing overlapping.
Let's try one little thought loop.
So let's start with Blue's question of what does an organizational representation look
like?
So we'll start in that very top left cell and then shift the focus towards the structural
components and then challenge the structural representation, but stay within the structural
domain and then see if that can result to us making it back to a non-representational
organizational framing.
So what is a good organizational?
Well, something that is classic vanilla organizational representation, well, that's something that
is well separated in terms of variables inside and outside the system.
So we're not worried about the structure of the variables inside or outside, just that
they are separated.
So computers seem like pretty clear cases where within a program, you could have variables
that by design are separated through like an intermediate variable or computers and hardware,
like two computer systems could be totally separated except for an interface like a USB
port or something.
But of course, this paper is about that strange loop when it's a cognizing agent, an adaptive
active inference agent doing that, representing not necessarily a mere active agent, but should
we use a computational example or some sort of enacted human example?
You got a good example right here on the page.
So how would we shift across the y-axis between organizational, representational, because I'm
assuming we're going clockwise, to representational structural.
That's not a hard example to make.
Yes, so in the human case, this would be like two humans in a conversation.
Outside of the conversation, when two humans are in conversation, there is separation in
terms of their sensory motor systems.
So we have checked the box for organizational, representational, starting in the top left
cell.
All right, now the question would be, is there structural representation?
So that would be like maybe if one person thought of a sentence and then said it, and
then the other person thought of that sentence too.
Would that qualify as a structural representation?
Because there's a structural resemblance in the model of the two conversions?
Yeah.
We could also find out if both of us were talking at the same time and suddenly stopped
turn taking, that the structure of that model would now fundamentally change.
It's still representational, and two people arguing over top of one another to the third
party isn't necessarily something comprehensible.
They're mine to the two people that are inside the conversation.
So when I think about conversation, something comes to mind recently, like really you need
to have the order of the language specified, like my son is reading now and he's five,
and he's taken the book like pop on pop, the doctor sees the book and he'll turn it upside
down and he'll say, dod, no, doe, and he'll read it that way, and then he wants to read
every sentence backwards from the end to the beginning, which I'm like, I don't care as
long as you're reading because it's a practicing reading, but the context is completely different.
When you're reading each word in the opposite order, so when you're talking about a structural
representation of a conversation, I think that there needs to be a literal representation
or at least a core screen representation of in what order things are said in order to
glean some kind of meaning, but then are we bleeding into the content related, but like
as we're, you know, that's why I really feel like, like, what are these different maps
look like and trying to maybe elucidate what the representations are is valuable because
I think when you have organization, okay, inside, outside, like this is the sentence
or he said this and she said that or whatever, and then you try to put structure on it, like
that gives it then content or context that they can then, you know, and so on and so
forth.
Dean.
No, I don't have much to add to that other than I just don't think that the, that this
loop that we've, we've just selected this, we said there was going to be a certain amount
of randomness in the last live stream and we've chosen this now, let's walk, let's walk
through it. I don't see it being difficult to, to follow that path and find examples.
So we have a superordinate right now, structurally, we want to carry out this directionality from
the representational side of things to the non-representational side and blue, if you're,
if your kid wants to turn the book upside down, that's, that's actually a feature, right?
Because they're not already stuck in this only one way of doing it thing. So yeah.
Let's complete the red loop and then the green and the orange will come into play. Okay. So
we started with two people in conversation. That's organizational separation of cognition.
This brings us to the structural facet, which is where there's a structural resemblance
in the representations of the conversions. So there, maybe it is the case where they're
both thinking about a similar topology of variables. So there's some structural representation.
But now let's stay within the structural column, go from B to C. Okay. So the two people are
in a conversation. It's kind of like a dance. So what if those two people's representation
is so different that it's actually not structurally resembling? So maybe one person is the more
experienced in the discipline and the other is less experienced, like one person's super
good at fixing motors, the other person is just has no idea. So the representation was
take would be like, well, they're both thinking about the motor. But then when we start to
see like, a cognitive asymmetry, all of a sudden, we fall out of structural representation
list between these two systems, because their cognitive models don't necessarily have similar
structure. Yes, Danielle. Oh, wait, unmute, then go for it.
So I might be missing something here, but I thought that we can only start to talk about
the structural dimension here. Once in this example, the two people in the conversation
are representing the same thing. And then the question is, how much information or how
does each of their representations do each of their representations have to look similar
to one another. But like, part of it has to be that they are representing the same thing.
That sort of necessary component. If they're not representing the same thing, then we're
having a different conversation. Well, that may come to the functional.
That might come to the content related like the novice and the expert, the representations
are both about the engine. But there's so structurally different in their representation
of the engine so that although the content in the aboutness of the representation is
similar, so still qualifying as a representation in that sense, there's a structural non resemblance
such that by that criteria in that situation, we've fallen out of the representational cell
B into something non-representational potentially. Blue, what do you think?
So I think like two people in a conversation can be trying to represent the same thing.
Like, yes, they both need to be trying to represent, have the same representation, like
they're trying to converge on a conversation, a meaningful conversation presumably. But
they don't always converge. And then that's where you get like misunderstandings or like,
you know, we both think that we think the same. We both agree that we're thinking that
we have the same structural representation, but perhaps they're different. And then and
then the communication breaks down. Okay, so the structures are so different
that we're recognizing it as a continuum from total overlap of structural resemblance to
total non overlap, but it would be important to specify that null hypothesis. So we've kind
of scooted into C. How do we stay in that space of like the novice and the expert who
have different cognitive representations and then use that to challenge even organizational
representationalism? Can I? Blue and then Dean first, and then blue.
Go ahead, Dean.
All right. I just thought I want to just go back to the to Daniel's point. So if we're
if we're structuring a conversation normally we turn take, but if we're playing in a band,
we're all playing at once and then we stop playing. So I think we can start with structure
two is just deciding how we want to signal. Right. So I don't think it I don't think there's
an necessarily an order that we have to start with organization first. We can actually start
with structure first as well.
Yeah, and I think a conversation is a particularly challenging example because we're representing
two things, but we're representing what the other person is trying to say and then presumably
what the conversation is about is something else in the world that we could be representing.
Exactly. So I think we're representing a degree of information sharing and I think that this
is going to like lump into out of polices, which I've been really wanting to kind of
get into. But but when we have like, I'm my own person and I'm communicating with Daniel
from, you know, 50,000 miles away, we both feel like we're getting on the same page.
And we actually like do get on the same page. Like, do we form some kind of like separate
cognitive unit? Like at what degree of model overlap is the degree of information sharing
so high that then we are worthy of our own Markov blanket, like we're sure that we understand
that we are the same unit. Right. And I think that this idea of self assembly and information
sharing and model overlap, what I think that there's an important path to traverse down
this way, because if you don't have full overlap of the model, like your or do you need full
overlap to form a self assembling system to be, you know, to form a higher level? It's
just an interesting thought.
That's kind of where the C to D transition takes us, which would be like, so we have
the drummers waiting for this and has a model resembling this, and then the singer has a
totally different structure. And then when we think about the whole cognitive system,
it doesn't deny what we recognize in a that there's still like the sensory motor separation
but we've reached that point by those people or rules being part of a larger, non separable
extended cognitive system. So almost by recognizing the interaction. So here we focused on the
separation in a and that's what granted us the representational cell, but we've returned
to seeing that partial information encapsulation within some type of broader structure, where
none of the entities have like the band level representation. So hopefully other people
can think of other like ABCD examples. But when we were at B, we kind of started branching
off into like talking about the content related things, the aboutness. So here it's like,
there are two people do have a structural resemblance in their internal model. And it's about the
same thing. But then what if one person sees the aboutness in such a different way that
again, we fall out of the content related representation. And then how would we move
from there back to see where all of a sudden the cognitive models in a sense don't have
structural representations resemblance, because they're about different things now. Danielle.
So would this be like in the case of two, two things that are so analogous that they
share a lot of structural similarities and things like that work that you can actually
draw lines between the individual aspects of the concepts, but they could be about totally
different things. But two people talking about these things can can form some sort of structural
similarity in the representations. And it's just like an entry point into being able to
think about all other things. But the aboutness really has nothing to do with it.
Um, Dean, then I might want to ask me on that.
I don't know if I don't know if this answers that Danielle, but from my space, I'm thinking
the difference between say a distracted driver who's looking down at their phone between
the seats and somebody who's got that information and heads up display on their windshield. Right.
So so content twice, but structurally presented one as a one as a distracted state and one
as a contiguous state. So I don't know if that answers your point, but I think we could
we know the difference, right? In terms of what where the where the content is structured
and how we're trying to contextualize each each matter. So
Again, staying with this sort of educational setting. What is it important to see a transference
or a new emergence of? Is it that the structural model of the learner is moving into more resemblance
with the teacher? Is it that the aboutness of the learner is moving towards the same
aboutness of the teacher? Or let's just remind about what the functional is supporting vicarious
use before or in the absence of external events. So does the teaching conversation? Will it
be a functional representation when vicariously without the teacher, the student can carry
out what the teacher could do, which might be having aboutness or not. It might be with
a structural cognitive resemblance or not. It might involve total informational isolation,
putting a squarely in a or it might involve some type of challenging of that in D.
The reason why there's not going to be, I think, a precise answer, because as the paper
lays out, even for the same scenario, people do have different perspectives. So it's not
like we're trying to take a scenario, then classify it into, well, that one's like an
A, B, E, G, or an A, C, E, H, like that is probably not what one of the outcomes could
be. But these are all perspectives that we could take on a given scenario. And they
do reveal interesting things about the systems of studies. Anything else to add on this sort
of like looping around the cells or should we push on? Push. Okay, Blue, what were you
thinking here? I was just taking notes. And so maybe we should talk about content related
and functional. So I was just taking notes on what these are. Organizational, like how
are the representations? And I was trying to draw a picture. So if you, I will draw my
picture if you will talk about maybe functional representation, like what does a functional
representation look like? Or content related? What's inside of those? And then I will draw
my picture and then you can show it. Or I'll just draw it while you're talking.
Sure. So the content related is whether the generative models need to explicitly model
the ways external states produce sensations, environmental models, or the ways actions
produce sensations. Is it really important that internal states resemble external states?
Or is it sufficient that they afford accurate action control? So let's just say there's
a spotlight that's shining photons onto the eye. The content of the cognitive representation
would be more in the representational camp if the cognitive model were truly explicitly
modeling the ways in which the photons hit the retina. Maybe. But this or is a bit challenging
because the way actions produce sensations, that could be a model of like, well, if I
blink, it becomes darker. And when I open my eyes, it's lighter. But that's a totally
disjoint question from understanding how a spotlight works. But those two scenarios
of the spotlight's cognitive explicit modeling, the environmental model, or the sensory motor
model of blinking and it becoming darker, those are both contents related. And, Dean?
Well, I don't know if this helps or not. But one of the things that I used to bring up
around this idea was the puzzle concept. So you got a box and it says a thousand piece
puzzle. And when you open up the box, is that representational or is it not representational
until you've figured out whether all thousand pieces have now been duly assembled, right?
So from a content perspective, do you have what you need in order to be able to tell
the difference between something which is representative and that which is not? So again,
I don't know if that's helpful in terms of sort of trying to see a difference between
that, say, and structure, like where it's placed relative to the context or not. But
that was the way I tried to surface it.
One evolution or handshake that hinges on that or of the environmental models and the
sensory motor models, they do unpack a little bit. So one approach consists in starting
from the sensory motor models. So that would be when I blink, it becomes darker when my
eyes are open, it's lighter, but progressively extends them to incorporate extra variables
that describe external causes of sensation. So like if there's a light on one side, but
not on the other side, then it can be the case that that blinking is true, no matter
how you're turned. But then that could be enriched or augmented with a model of parameters
that describes external causes of sensation, like there's a light over there and not over
there. And so actually that little loop that we just took was from the sensory motor B,
the sensory motor model in B, moving to a representational model of the content, like
there's a light over there. And then does that, well, at least that was the BTE move.
But then maybe that could do something else. So maybe blue will clarify there. But let's
go back to just review functional, like, what is the functional and it's good to revisit
these in the zero one, two, three, four, five, because it's the contribution of the paper.
And maybe there are other facets, other columns to add, and there's just a lot of complexity
even as this is. So the functional one is about supporting vicarious use before or in
the absence of external events. So in that story with the lights and the blinking, it
only had that model only has to be instantiated while the in that room with the photons hitting
the eye and the blinking happening. However, we can imagine a situation that's vicariously
detached or before that setting, like what would happen if there were a light over here
and a light over here, and it was the case that blinking made it darker. And this is
where they trace back to PSA that representations should vicariously stand for something external
in their absence and afford vicarious operations. So there's a light over on the left side,
you reach over and you unscrew it. What is in your hands? Now that is
seeming to be in the functional facet, because we're talking about the role the representation
is playing. And the fact that it is standing for something external in the absence, there's
no physical light that we're talking about. It's not like we're unscrewing it and then
verifying that it's in our hands. Who's for and against that?
What functional roles do internal models play during free energy minimization? And does
minimization require the internal manipulation of variables in ways that resemble vicarious
operations in the classical PSA account of representation?
Yes, blue. So this might be like, I don't know, maybe
it's the easiest and also the hardest to get a grip on. So if we have a representation
of internal variables that are functional, like a functional internal representation,
is this like doing, like you manipulate the variables internally and then manipulate them
externally, like you plan to reach for the cup to take a drink of water. And then you
reach for the cup to take a drink of water, but you have to have like the internal execution
prior to or maybe simultaneous with the external execution. Is that like functional representation,
like you plan the action and do the action, maybe separate or maybe together? Is that
what functional representation looks like? Let's go with the reaching for the cup. Because
as Danielle noted, like conversation, improvised spontaneous conversation of reflexive entities
is one of the hardest cases. But it's the one that we have. So that's awesome. But we're
going to be talking about a adaptive active inference agent reaching for a mere active
inference agent. So in the Sims, other paper we discussed, now we're talking about the
case of unidirectional integration, rather than the multi scale reciprocal integration.
So the person is separated from the cup. There's a separation of the cognitive model
of the agent from the cup. The structural side, if the internal model is cup like, or
it features a cup variable touching a table variable, and then another edge that is engaged
of the hand touching the cup, for example, that might be a structural similarity. But
I think that's part of the debate is, how could there be a structural similarity when
it's not a cup in your brain, which we kind of talked about last time, like, how could
you have something that structurally resembles a car? If it's your brain and body, the contents
related encoding environmental contingencies or sensory motor contingencies. So it could
be the case that a certain sensory motor action will result in picking up and grasping the
cup, whereas another sensory motor action is going to result in the shattering of the
cup. And that could be analyzed in terms of correctness. The functional representational
question would be like the vicarious detachments of the sensory motor loop from the cognition.
So then it would be like, if you were to pick up that cup, then you dumped it, what would
happen? And then someone says like, well, water would fall out. So in that case, it is
like there's a functional representation, whether or not it resembles the structure
of the cup, there's a functional representation, because that idea of grasping the cup, it's
able to be operated on internally vicariously in the absence of direct stimuli related to
the cup. Dean.
Do you mind if I just read right from the paper for a second, because I think it helps
in terms of this difference between the automaticity and reflective aspects of this action. One
important implication falling out of this diagnosis is that when considering functional
rural aspects, it's often how the details of our chosen process theories are fleshed
out and contextualized by the kinds of cognitive phenomena that we are attempting to account
for for that skew or that skew, our interpretation of FEP in one direction or another. For example,
one may consider that there are core aspects of FEP, such as the possession of a Markov
blanket and more ancillary aspects. And I think ancillary is the key here, such as the
possibility, but not the necessity to engage in counterfactual inference, which is only
required for planning. And it is only the latter more ancillary aspects that call for
a representational interpretation under a given process theory. This would imply that
when using functional role as a sole criterion for representational processes, only some
FEP agents, namely those that can engage in counterfactual forms of inference would meet
the criteria for representation. It is only this subset of FEP agents that would be equated
to full fledged predictive processing agents. So there is an automaticity part to this where
it's really not a Markov blanket, you just do it almost subconsciously. And that's again,
the authors are trying to point this out. Yes, if we fail, I drop the cup and now I reflect
on that. That's the representational piece. But prior to that, I was just going through
the motions. I didn't need a set of instructions telling me to reach out for the cup. So that's
just in the author's words.
Thanks a lot for clarifying that it's like, yes, if one is reflexively grasping at it
or accidentally, then it then grasping the cup, like if you're if you're groping around
in a dark room, and then you happen to grasp the cup, it doesn't have to be representational
because there isn't a counterfactual. And that's very interesting how they say that
it is ancillary. So that's kind of like secondary or not essential to it. Because we can imagine
an active inference entity that's taking in sensory observations, updating its generative
model, engaging in policy selection, and then resulting in some action output impacting
the niche and the cycle begins again. That can be just like a single layer model that
doesn't engage in counterfactuals. But they raise that notion that it's only the counterfactuals
in cognition that actually give us the space to have a functional representation. It's
like if the shell just represents the shell, can't be anything else. But then there's another
kind of entity who can see the shell as financial, or can see it in a different way. And then
it's those counterfactuals that enable the shell to play a functional representational
role in that it stands for something else. Blue, what is this imagery on the bottom?
So I just was like trying to really look at or like try to visualize what would these different
like representations really look like, right? If we take like the idea of two, a person
and a cup even, right? Okay, so on the first one, right, we have organizational. So like
I am a thirsty body. I'm contained within me. There is a cup that contains water over
there. Like I know my boundary, I know the boundary of the cup, and the representation
looks like this. And then a structural representation is just me and the cup and my relationship
between me and the cup, right? So do I have to also have like, so my real question here
is, do these perhaps build on one another? So here you have the structural and then
the next one would be content related. Do I also have to have this connecting line in
the content related? Is that required? Like do I have to have an idea of the structure
to understand the content? And then in the functional, like do you need to know the content
and the structure and the organizational to have to have an understanding of the function?
Right? Do I need to know like the content related like, I know that there's water in
the cup, right? I assume that there's water in the cup. To find out, I have to realize
that there's an inside of me and outside of me and inside of the cup and outside of the
cup. I have to realize my relationship between me and the cup and then to find out the content,
like I have to go sample the cup like just who was inside of it and I have to know what's
inside of me. And then the function, like can I only, like I wonder if there's water
in that cup? Like and then if I go to drink it and there's like whiskey in it or something,
like I'm not going to understand the function until I have all of those things layered on
top of each other. And so that's kind of really my question here in Daniel's drawing on my
drawings. But really, like I just wonder if there's levels of increasing complexity between
these different kinds of representations or if it's just merely the structure, the organizational
and I don't need these boundaries between self and cup in these other models, maybe
it's just the line without the circles in the structural or the no external circles and
content related. So I just want to know like what you guys maybe think of that if there
is a layering here, because I was kind of layering them up, but I don't know if that's
really the right mental representation. Thanks, Blue.
Dean? I'm not muted. Good. I think that I think there's two parts to this. One is that
we are able to differentiate, which is what the table allows for. And I think that the
second part is the the arrow, the curved arrow that Daniel drew, which essentially represents
boundary crossing number one. So the difference between something that's static and something
that is translatable. And then the second part of it, I think without going back down the
rabbit hole that we almost fell into him in the point one of this, when we started talking
about free will and can and will and the orthogonal piece of that, I think what it what it speaks
to maybe is that it's not a question of free or or encapsulated. It's it's a degree of
dependency question when you when you throw that curved line on on this sort of tiled
representation and start moving across a boundary. So I don't want to call it degrees of dependency
will up to a point of passing through zero. But I'd like to because I think there is an
aspect of that. And that's why I think it's kind of it's kind of crazy if we just focus
on the static things instead of the moving around the moving through four squares is what
I really think gives our minds a good workout. Yep. So here's another little workout. So
blue had two circles in relationship. So here, the circle is going to reflect an adaptive
active inference agent, or the full fledged predictive processing agent one that can engage
in counterfactuals. So the top is two adaptive entities in relationship, and the triangle
is going to reflect a mere active inference entity like a cup, or just something that
doesn't engage in counterfactuals. So organizational is the separation of the systems. So that's
very similar, because it's just describing there being a Markov blanket separating the
systems. The structural representation is having vehicles that are structurally similar.
So it's simple or in the lower case, triangle out there in the world. Is there a structural
resemblance that would be very representational? Whereas if they were cognitively imagining
something different than a triangle, that would have less resemblance. But that gets
challenging with adaptive adaptive, because we're modeling ourselves modeling each other,
blah, blah, blah. So here's them modeling the conversation. And that's where they're
sort of like, very complex dynamics, which is how can we have a structural similarity
about a conversation with another person? But it's simpler in the adaptive mirror case.
The content related representations encode environmental contingencies or sensory motor
contingencies. So like in this case, the triangle, it is the case that it can rotate clockwise.
And so this entity does have a good content related representation if it can actually
turn the dial to that way. And again, that's a little bit more complex in the reciprocal
case. But in the unidirectional case, this red arrow is a content related representation
of the actual motion in the world. And then this last case is the functional representation.
And here it still is, it could be more structural. So like more about the actual structure of
the cognitive model, or it could be more about the encoding of the contingencies. But the
key piece is this isolation, which isn't a Markovian isolation. This is actually the
true vicarious separation of. So here the person or the entity is able to engage in
either structural pondering of the triangle, or functional pondering of the triangle in
the absence of seeing the triangle or grasping the triangle. And again, though, that's a
little bit complex when you have multiple counterfactual cognizers asking each other
questions.
I just added a counterfactual to your, to your question.
Yeah, exactly. The red one is, then there's the blue one, it could go a different way.
And then this is, this is how we know that it's a true cognizer and a true functional
representation. Yes, great call. Thanks a lot, blue, because it has to do with a vicarious
nature with not directly seeing it. But it also has to do with that representation, whether
more structural, triangular, or more functional, red arrow could be different. So there's
them having a counterfactual action contingency. And here they're also imagining a counterfactual
structural position. Okay, I'm going to go to a question from Steven in the chat. Steven
asked, how do we resolve the use of the term functional as used in correlational dynamics?
So that's referring to some of our earlier discussions on like functional and effective
connectivity in neuroimaging and the term functional in use and the term functional
in terms of having cognitive counterfactuals. So how is the functional here related to effective
and functional connectivity in neuroimaging and time series statistics? I'll give a first
thought. It's not that it can't be linked or connected, but they are different namespaces
and they're totally different. The functional connectivity in the time series is about how
changes in one variable through time influence another variable through time or are associated
with changes in the other one through time. So it's not a mechanistic causal relationship
per se, but it's just that changes in one variable have an edge reflecting how changes
in some other variable change. That does not engage either of the pieces that we're highlighting
here, which is the vicarious or standing for nature, nor the counterfactual nature.
So it is a different use of the term functional. Functional is an overloaded word. And so
yeah, it's not that you couldn't have a paper that was looking at functional representation
and using neuroimaging and using functional and effective connectivity of brain regions
while individuals were engaged in functional representation. But that would a little bit
be like the star was the star of the movie. It's just using a word in multiple senses
in a way that may give some ambiguity to those who don't parse out the different senses
extremely clearly. Is that fair to say? Or does anyone have a different thought? Functional
can also mean teleological, like the function of something essentially. So there's many
uses of function. And I think it's interesting that it has come up in these different spaces.
Lou. So I do agree that they're disconnected, but I am able to perhaps see a relationship
in functional connectivity and also in counterfactuals. So when things are functionally connected,
one drives the other. And then the counterfactual is when things are not functionally connected,
there's no corresponding correlation. So in the exploration of functional connectivity,
you have to have all of the data points over a time series. So you understand functional
connectivity through the exploration of counterfactuals. Does that make sense?
Okay. How about this? Functional connectivity, the term, it is a functional representation
that cognitive scientists use because it could be otherwise. They're engaging and they're
saying region A and B have functional connectivity because I did a time series statistics in
SPM, and we got this value. And so that functional connectivity value is able to be used in subsequent
internal cognitive representations. It stands for something, and it can be engaged with
in a counterfactual way, like what if it would have been stronger, then what would our conclusion
have been or what if it would have been weaker, what would it have been? And then Stephen
wrote, these definitions, these are definitions and ways to name could be where the ontology
working group could have a future role. Yes, ontology development in active inference,
and how will we even make the decisions of what terms to use and what senses and disambiguate
the uses and the different corpuses that we are looking at. So pretty interesting, this
graphic actually, I hope any of the authors or anyone who is like interested in this topic,
what do you think about these doodles? Do you agree, disagree? Let's go to blue's question
about auto poisons. What is like interesting or that about?
Just really where it comes in, and I think we kind of brought it up earlier in our, in
the sharing of a model, like so is sharing of a generative model necessary for self assembly
or even the attempt to share a generative model? Is that a necessary component of auto poisons?
And at what level, like organizationally, structurally, content related, functionally,
like at all the levels, I just wonder like how these things are related and when we were
talking earlier about having a conversation and trying to make your models align with
one another through information sharing. And like we saw with the computational boundary
of a self, about self assembly and auto poisons via Mike Levin, just about the informational
sharing between subunits leads to the formation of a larger cognitive unit. And so I was just
wondering about model relationships and forming a larger cognitive unit, like we're talking
about the conversation and then we form, we've complete overlap of yes, we get it, we rock,
we're there, and then we form a larger cognitive unit. And is that on all aspects, is it just
related to content, structure, organization, or function, or all of the above, just what
anybody thinks about that?
Right. And we saw this actually in Matt Sims earlier paper, the biological symbiosis, right?
Yes. The auto poetic system is capable of producing and maintaining itself by creating
its own parts. So it's kind of like the ship of theseus plus crew, they're able to be
modifying and reconstructing the material basis of the system. On one hand, that maintains
an organizational separation of like the cell and the surrounding in terms of the realist
interpretation of a Markov blanket. At the same time, the auto poetic process does not
need to have, well, it involves ingressing and outgressing material. So that does blur
the boundary. And structurally, it doesn't need to be the case that the auto poetic process
of the cell has like a blueprint or a structural resemblance of the cell. It could just be
subunits that are non representational. They cannot engage. It doesn't even make sense
to ask whether the cognitive model has structural similarity with the target, because it's a
non cognitive entity. And similarly, on the functional side, the enzymes can't engage
in counterfactuals that, you know, synthesize the lipids and add them to the membrane. So
is information a representation?
I don't know. I mean, we're getting getting into the quantum now. So, yeah,
where's, where's information in this? It comes up in the paper. 1817 times. Based on
local information, information comprises the generative model, past and present information,
future information, information gain, no additional information about internal states, that's
the Markov definition. High mutual information can be in the context of a non representational
generalized synchrony, like the pendulums that synchronize. Where is the information
in this eight fold distinction?
So the author talked about here, if I can read a quote quickly, if one only appeals
to the organizational aspect of representation, the presence of environmental or sensory
motor or complex or frugal model does not matter. Insofar as the internal variables
of the model are understood to be separated from external reality by a Markov blanket
and the generative model is leveraged to infer the causal structure of external reality via
self evidencing. However, these differences matter if one considers structural aspects
and the degree of resemblance between hidden variables and environmental dynamics, as opposed
to action or information gathering dynamics. So, I don't know, here the content of representations
is used to draw a further distinction within the representational view between an internalist,
sometimes called intellectualist or encodist, versus an action oriented perspective. So.
Probably one of the most thrilling academic debates. Dean.
Well, please don't. Don't judge what I'm about to say next. Just bear with me, be kind.
So in this representation, for example, where we've got this table, if we were to look at
those lines, each one of those horizontal lines, because there's three I see, and each
one of those vertical lines, because there's four I see. And we realized, and we realized
them as an standard X, Y graph. We know that there's a relationship between X and Y, that
every one of those horizontal lines relative to Y has a zero component to it. And we know
that every one of those vertical lines relative to X has a zero component to it. So most
people will look at the blackness of that relative to the white background, and they'll
just see something material separating. But if we actually look at it graphically, and
we take Daniel's idea of the tetrahedron, every time we round an edge and change direction
on that tetrahedron, there is a zero element that allows for that boundary crossing that
we, again, don't pay as much attention to. And so from a from an auto poetic standpoint,
you can actually see where something like a Markov blanket both separates and leaves
the potential open for that transfer or that crossing or that transition. So when we're
modeling ourselves, the last paragraph of the section five of the paper, they wrote
arriving at an MVP as synthesis. So some some non zero number and zero view depends upon
which representational criterion. We are assuming when either considering MVP central constructs
or considering specific cognitive phenomena through the lens of a process theory under
MVP, do we include the zero piece of this or not tentatively, fully, or do we willfully
ignore it? Hence in the end, the debate about MVP may reveal more about us, our criteria,
whether we want this to be a material thing and not not include the zero aspect of it.
And our interest in particular facets of cognition than does about the representational status
of MVP. So I just want to kind of bring that again, don't judge me because I could be way
wrong here and I may be overfitting. But I think that the auto poetic part of it, we
can see both the separation and we can see the the portal in a line, if we choose to
include both. That's kind of what I wanted to bring up.
Okay, very interesting Dean, thanks. Here's the unfolded tetrahedra. There's a few unfold
there's a few shapes of paper that can be folded into a tetrahedra one looks more like
a parallelogram. And one looks more like an equilateral triangle, we're just kind of like
folds up like the petals of a flower. So these zero lines. So there's the zero point of within
a facet, representational and non representational, that's almost like the two sides of the paper,
like how many triangles are here? Oh, four. How about eight? How many units? How many
triangle units of paint do you need to paint this for? No, eight, two sides. So the zero
is like the thickness of the paper. And that's also when you fold it up, that's like inside
versus outside of the tet. And then these zero Y lines are like the movements from one face
to another face, where it's also thin enough as to be imperceptible, especially when it's
laid flat. But it makes all the difference to move from one side to another. How do we
use moving through zero in this eight fold or other cognitive models? How do we use that
to increase the efficacy or the fluidity or the accessibility of models? Does it help
us in explaining that we're not locked out of that self organization loop that we can
actually participate in it? Is that the first thing that it tells us that we're not locked
out of that ability to self generate? That was a question that wasn't that I wasn't questioning
that was it was an like an honest, sincere question.
I think so. One supportive or complementary component would be this is sort of a map. This
is like a cognitive map. And someone could say, this side of the paper is better than
the other side. And this is my favorite face. But it's presented as part of a larger knowledge
structure such that the learner could engage in counterfactuals, like what if we were on
the other side of the paper, or what if we were on a different face? So this allows,
for example, individuals to reflect their understanding of the lay of the land, but also communicate
their preferences. And as the paper shows, different individuals do have different outcomes
in terms of their cognitive conclusions. And that's what reveals the super fascinating
thing about us. And that's why the paper is modeling ourselves, what the free energy
reveals about our implicit notions of representation, not free energy principle modeling representation,
what the free energy principle reveals about representation, which would be a slightly
different paper and title. So just the scholarship and the sense making phase that only very
few have to engage in, like Samson Pazulo have, is to make these maps and then bring
the perspectives that were not integrated to be shown as just different locations in
a phase space. Like we put four zeros, but so it's not as simple as just like two numbers.
But you know, if there was, if it was just two topics being against each other, every
perspective could have like a position in that phase space. And then what do we do with
that? Yes, Danielle,
I guess I'm thinking about the ourselves part of modeling ourselves. I'm not really thinking
about all humans and the way that our minds work. It's more of the academic conversations
that have been happening around the sort of intellectual tradition that's been happening
around representation. And so this the contribution of this paper, as I see it, is that, look,
we've got this framework that does a lot of work for us in a lot of different disciplines.
And if we apply it to this conversation, this intellectual debate that's been happening,
we can reveal implicit assumptions of the debate itself. And what emerges is that perhaps
as an artifact of particular examples that have been used to understand representation,
we see one side of the coin or another. We can see these, we pull on these different
dimensions that are laid out in this paper. So I guess it's just important to think about
and disagree if you disagree. But the ourselves is really just about the way that philosophers
and and cognitive scientists have been thinking about this. Nothing is true. This is not revealing
something about cognition per se. It's it's more about the implicit assumptions that have
been kind of unfolding and how how we're thinking about the the discipline.
Thanks for that. Just like there was a sort of hinge on the functional being used in two
different ways, another sense of representation, one that might be more commonly used outside
of cognitive science would be like representation in terms of different perspectives or identities
in a group. And then that made me think of nothing about us without us, which is used
in different contexts, but basically has to do with participatory decision making that
decisions are not being made in a way removed from the people who it influences. And that
has to do with representation, no taxation without representation, for example. And so
cognitive science is actually in a nothing about us without us. Because if there's just
an academic discussion, especially an unexamined one with a lot of implicit baggage about a
hyper intellectualized hyper abstracted scenario, or like we like to study representational
organizational cases where it's super clean, these are the ones that we study, these are
the model systems, these are the kind of careers that have been built in academia, for example.
But it's about us in the broader sense, like humans, and then even us as cognitive entities.
And so it is the philosophers and the literature that is in this paper, as Danielle kind of
highlighted, that's the modeling ourself. The selves there are the participants in the
discussion around representation, which of course has been textual abstract, English
speaking, qualitative, other adjectives. So it's another interesting connection there.
So definitely like the subjectivity that Danielle highlighted is a big part of perhaps why we
have these organizational structural, these different like viewpoints. But maybe something
that I don't think is really emphasized too much in this paper is kind of the realist
versus instrumentalist viewpoint of active inference. And so there's a pretty big argument
in the literature. And I think probably the math is not the territory, maybe gets into
it the best, maybe in the most detail of the papers that we've studied here on this stream.
But you know, there's people that say like active inference is a way to model the cognitive
process or the action perception process that we all undergo. And then there are people
who say that this is actually happening in a computational way in the brain. It's not
a model of it is how it works. And so there's this ongoing, like vision fusion feud happening
in the active inference community also. And I just wanted to highlight that because, yeah,
because you may not know. Thanks a lot, blue. I pulled out a few quotes because I also noticed
that when we it was one of the earlier quotes when we were talking about the, I think, organizational
element. So look at how often reality comes into play in these discussions. So internal
variables of a model. Okay, so we're talking about instrumentalism, right? Like models
are understood to be separated from external reality by a Markov blanket. Wait, reality?
And the generative model model is leveraged to infer the causal structure of external
reality. So it flips four times in that sentence from reality, from model to reality, back
to model, back to reality. It's a very, it doesn't make it right or wrong. It's just
a very interesting epistemic artifact. Because within the reality of the model, like the
reality of the map, it is the case that the internal variables are separated. And if the
model is trying to do determination on that level of reality, like maps trying to infer
maps, that is reality. But then that's not the sort of layer one external reality in
the sense that many people often mean or use it. Dean?
Yeah, I think, Danny, if you take the word reality and model and push them out into even
more extreme tales, you could you could see the model, you can see people who are pushing
back against the model idea. And they're arguing, you're just too rigid, right? You're just
too stuck. And you can see people that are taking the non-representational sort of reality
view, the variance maintainer retained view, as say, you can see the people that are on
the model end of the continuum saying, that's just chaos. There's nothing about that that
we can actually make sense of because the cognitive overload right now is just swamping
me, right? And so I think what these authors were trying to do is say, well, can we move
back and forth instead of getting stuck on those really far out positions in terms of
this in terms of this way of being able to see when we have these densities, right? And
then out of those densities, how do those densities re reset back to some sort of invariance
and then re reform, right? So I think that's, and I hope that kind of speaks to what Daniel
was saying too, because sure, we can we can point out the most extreme example, like at
the very end of the continuum, or we can actually talk about how we're going to draw these unidirectional
or bi-directional lines and boundary cross. And I think that's what they were trying to
open us our thinking up to. But maybe maybe I'm just being Pollyanna here because I really
like the paper on them.
Interesting point. Here's some realism is also used in another way, which is kind of like
it's a school of literature or a thread of literature. And so then I found this paper
affective realism evoke realism beyond representation. And so this is in the case of literary expression.
So that's an activity that cognitive entities are engaged in. And we just see a lot of terms
that we talk about in active, like agency, affect process. And here it's not about reality,
but some territory, it's like realization. And realization is an interesting word. And
I know Verveke and others use it as well, because realization, it is about the model.
But when something is realized, it becomes real in the model. But usually we wouldn't
say that something is realized like, oh, I just realized that zebras have nine legs.
It's like you engage in a counterfactual. But is it a realization if the model is updated
in a way that isn't concordant with reality? And I agree that the paper gives us a lot
of nuance to talk about these areas, because we can talk about how, well, the isolation
of the variables doesn't change, or the structure of the legs and the zebra doesn't change
or it can still run, right? So why not nine legs? Is it still a zebra? There's a lot of
open threads, but the way that they use model and reality in light of a lot of the other
discussions we've had is really illustrative. Blue?
So one of my favorite things to think about in terms of the realism versus the instrumentalism
is the Markov blanket. I was looking for the picture of the person sleeping under the Markov
blanket, like really as a partition for a system, like, do systems have Markov blankets?
Or can they be modeled with Markov blankets? And I always just think of that cute little
picture with the little person sleeping under the Markov blanket. Do I have a Markov blanket
wrapped around me? Because that's really where it tends to break down in my mind. Yes, there's
a boundary, but I'm not sure that it's a Friston blanket or a Pearl blanket or a Markov blanket,
like maybe it's just skin. Yes, Dean?
I hate answering a question with another question, but in the conclusion of the paper, the authors
speak specifically to the free energy principle can be very heuristic. And so I'm wondering
in the instrumentalist versus realist debate whether it has to necessarily get up to that
abstract level of Markov blanket, or whether we can just say that sandwich between those
two are rules that we demarcate, that we lay down and that we have act as a parsing mechanism.
I don't know. What do you think, Blue? Like, are rules things that we can just get our
hands on right today instead of having to go all the way up to figuring out what a Markov
blanket is under this set of circumstances? No, I can definitely rule. So I mean, we all
agree that there are lots in physics. Like if you drop an apple, it will fall to the
floor. We all abide by these rules. They might not apply at every scale, but I definitely
think that a rule-based construction or understanding, like does that then bridge the realism versus
instrumentalism debate, perhaps? So building on the point that the ourselves in the title
is the people reading the paper. So not just like people in the psych department, but it's
the ourselves, the people who are in that epistemic commons. So using that, but also the contents
related representations in terms of correctness or truth. So if that, if the ourselves are
those who are pondering FEP, then the heuristic that they refer to, we conclude by highlighting
the heuristic power of the FEP to advance our understanding of the notion of internal
representation. It is pretty meta because we're representing the debate about people
representing the debate about representation. However, the fact that it has a heuristic utility
within the contents related aspect, at the very least, it does have representational
impact. I'm not sure where that takes us. There's probably other ways to take it, but
I think something about the diversity of conclusions that people have and how that shines a light
back on us or is a mirror and how the FEP has been applied here in this paper as a heuristic
for sense making in this meta debate says something, I hope, Danielle.
I hope I'm addressing what you're saying and not taking this in another direction, but
stepping back, I'm thinking of FEP as just one of many different tools of thought that
we have that allow us to align our representations. And if it is an effective tool, we all start
having a conversation that makes sense to each other, that's mutually intelligible.
In this case, it is kind of meta because it's about how the academics, the intellectual
conversation about representations have failed to converge on something. There's this debate,
there are many layers of the debate. And so what it reveals is that we haven't yet converged,
like the community hasn't converged. And so FEP is this thing that we can use that reveals
those things and allows us to then better, because it's revealing these things, we can
all attend to those things that were implicit and are now made explicit, we're converging
our representations. So I think that kind of addresses what you're saying, it's about
representations, but it's also this tool, like there are many other types of tools that
allow us to realize what we've been taking for granted and align our representations.
Thanks a lot, Dean. Yeah, just to add on to that. If you're like me, you think rules
and tools are interchangeable. And the other thing you think is that if it's a heuristic,
it speaks kind of that to that vicarious function in terms of content. So I just want to throw
that on top because I think there's some agreement around that.
We use the rules to make that next vicarious play the next before we make the next move.
So I mean, anybody that doesn't is kind of kidding themselves, I think, but maybe I'm
wrong. Okay, here's a little bit of FEP in a heuristic
case. So we've talked about the Helmholtz decomposition of vector fields, like in stream
number 32, about how there's this pragmatic or sort of hill climbing or gradient descending
component, whether you take the optimistic biology, climbing mountain probable, go straight
up the mountain of fitness, or the physicists gradient descent into the bottom of the well.
In either case, there's that irrotational component that's associated with pragmatism.
And then there's this epistemic component that's associated with the solenoidal isocontor.
So we've talked about that Helmholtz decomposition. So here's one way in which the FEP is being
heuristically applied. So Danielle said, the academic conversation
on representation has not converged, and it has not converged, and it has also not
even coherent. Like, there isn't a shared ontology, there's not a shared narrative,
there's not shared words or regime of attention or what people are even focused on. And so
what the FEP is doing, literally like they did here, with this distinction, it does a
few things, it, it holds space for not overfitting, like, let's just say in 2055, all the people
in the world are all the cognitive scientists, they all agreed, Oh, great, we converged.
Just lock that in. But FEP even then will remind us like not to overfit, and also not
to center one side of the tetrahedra, we could say, this is the side that has these attributes
or we focus on this side for these reasons. And no one goes there to this other side,
or there's a reason why we don't go there, or we take a journey, we travel through there,
but we don't live there or something like that. It brings a level of coherence to the
discussion that doesn't necessarily have the goal of perfect static convergence. But still
there'll be solenoidal flow and differences in opinion, even then. Who said the FEP wasn't
useful?
Well, and maybe this is obvious, but is, is that not what any good theory does? Like
Blue said, well, gravity is true, because if I drop an apple, it will fall. Yeah. So
the theory of gravity does the same thing. It allows us to converge our representations.
It's just that the theory of gravity is not itself about representation.
Yes. This, this is like the hall of mirrors, this paper and conversation, because it is
like it's the group of people in the hall of mirrors, and they're all wearing mirror
suits in a weird way. But it is our gym for building the kind of frameworks that then can
reduce our uncertainty a ton, potentially in similar cases. And the strange loop of reflexive
cognitive entities is going to be this open-ended bount for a long time to come. But just like
how we started here with a really complex reciprocal case of two adaptive entities,
but then it was a lot less ambiguous here. And I wonder if ACTIMF informed system design
will frame an increasing amount of pieces, especially in a digital world, into this bottom
tier, offloading some of the repetitive tasks, attention consuming tasks, anxiety producing
stimuli, into these type of interactions, which opens up new spaces for these kinds
of interactions with the two adaptive entities.
To return to that, having or possessing a Markov blanket, just one quick point was,
which we already even read the quote, which was a core aspect of FEP, such as the possession
of a Markov blanket. So is the Markov blanket the system? Or does it have one? Those are
both realist. Or is it modeled as having? Is it modeled as being? Those are instrumentalist
ways of similar framings. And how do we know what the core aspects are? What does that
stem from? So there's a ton to learn and discuss there. And then let's look at any in just
our last few minutes, any of the other topics. And if anybody wants to highlight one of these
or also maybe as we jump off from 36.2 to 37 and beyond, when we discuss free energy
a user's guide, but also we just continue on our paths, like, why does it matter? Not
all these papers maybe make the argument for why this whole representation debate matters.
So what is the pragmatics that make this meaningful, make it important to fund people working on
it or the way that influences the technologies that we're developing, rather than just a
pure info gain reduction of uncertainty question. So any topics here, or any like thoughts on
how this will or could or should influence our action selection going forward?
I'm comfortable with long silences, but I'm going to throw this out there. I think people
will be able to use this tool to become more creative, not just be able to reduce or minimize
their prediction errors, but actually have the confidence to come up with new and different
ways of looking at problems that we probably didn't have in our tool kit before in terms
of being able to come up with something different. And so I think the first thing that it does
is it allows for a boundary crossing that maybe we constructed in our minds before,
but we're seeing less and less of it as being a hard stop. And there's now maybe a little
bit more, more say in whether to go or don't go. So that's what I would think that this
kind of work is maybe opening up unless somebody comes and shuts it down. And I can't speak
to what outside forces would find terribly threatening, but I'm sure there are some out
outside. Blue? So I'm not sure if this has any pragmatic value, but I'm certainly interested
in kind of really exploring like sensory motor engagement and structural representation
and maybe like synesthesia. I know Daniel's been to Meow Wolf, but like, you know, when
you're playing these invisible like the invisible harp, you know, and like, could you structure
a room, like draw a map in a room? And your goal is to like kind of like an escape room,
but your goal is to find navigate your way through based on sound, right? Like you ting
the things and you have to find the right sound. You play Mary Had a Little Lamb and
then you get to your prize at the end or you get to get out of the room. And so as I wonder
creatively, like Dean was saying, like really these maps, these representations, can we
get literally out of our own representation and into the feeling of an alternate representation?
And what would that feel like or be like? And that's also why I brought up like blindness.
Like, you know, if you ever wake up in like a totally like my power went out the other
night, it was like black, I mean, no moon, nothing, like, it's just like, whoa, total
darkness, right? Like no little blue light from the plug or nothing. So in these like
total darkness situations, you have this representation of like, what is my house look like? Where
is my flashlight? Like you have to be able to navigate yourself in a totally dark situation.
Which is very foreign to go find a flashlight. And so I like these kind of boundary pushing
experiences and because they really force us to examine our own model and perhaps allow
us to explore the kind of models that other people use.
Thinking through other minds is this case with adaptive agents in dialogue. And it's
it's like thinking through other representations and this paper and discussion opens up not
to then simply converge but opens up and holds ways to think and act through other types
of representations, not just the same type, but in a different cognitive entity.
It comes up a lot. And it'd be awesome to see how just as so many other themes that we've
had raised by very prescient papers, like 14, math is not the territory, 20, Emperor's
new Markov blanket and some of the further nuancing about the Markovian assumptions.
This representational and non-representational and these words like organization structure
content and function, they will come up again. And maybe they'll be citing this paper. Maybe
they won't. But like, it's almost like when we see in a future paper just one facet of
the Tet and they'll say, here's how it is. It's this one side and it's like, well, no,
there's other sides and we could be inside or we could be outside. And someone could
still say, I prefer this one, but we know there's a bigger system that we can at least
come to the table around Dean. I'm not I'm not marketing, but it's going to come up
in 37. It's going to come up a bunch of times in 37. So that's just the next paper. So anyway,
hold out of your socks because if you think you have to wait for it to come up again,
it's going to come up again next week. So don't touch that dial.
Thanks a lot for the awesome sequence. This was a somewhat complex or intellectual paper.
I mean, they're all written, but this one was like challenging topics, a lot of different
perspectives. And then not only did they hold it open for all of the different perspectives,
but then rather than pick a winner, they flipped the table in the end and posed it not as
an answered competition for us to then have like domain specific clarity of action within,
but really a challenge on multiple levels for researchers who are familiar with FEP
and not the big question we asked was, can the free energy principle help us advance
or even resolve the long lasting debate on internal representation in philosophy of mind?
We certainly asked. So if anybody has any last comments they want to make on anything,
they're welcome to.
The last word, so I'll get this in real quick. I think that we're still arguing about whether
or not representation and modeling is heavily dependent, like that there is a dependency.
I think that the more philosophical views that we see come up around FEP and active
inference, the harder and harder it is to make the case that we can remove that dependency
or somehow just see the scale free aspects of this tool, that there's actually a heavy
dependency on what we're going to get out of representation or non-representation based
on our awareness or our realization that every time we cross a boundary, that is just
an independent act. That's a highly dependent act. So that'll be my last word.
So I just want to give a final comment. We talk about instrumentalism and realism and
then there's like third axis of utility. And I really think that this paper was super useful
in prompting new questions and holding up these different views of representation and
non-representation and in these different categories and allowing us to really kind of
view them through like a partitioned framework that I think will drive future questions and
really be useful in helping researchers formulate their theories.
Danielle, you're still here. Thanks for joining for your first stream. Do you have any last
comments?
Well, this was a wonderful introduction. I'm curious how representative it is of other
conversations. It was super heady in a really pleasant way.
It was not representative or representational of other conversations. No. Thanks a lot for
the awesome convo. Everyone's always welcome to join these discussions or other lab activities.
So thanks again to the authors and all the participants here. See you.